this is a circle of a moment but I'm
about to make it into a sphere so I can
do this pencil the way they help them
with a marker now at the moment we're
focusing on surface area just like we
did with the cylinder so you might
recall for a cylinder you need two
measurements right to know how wide this
cylinder is so that's the radius and
then you need to know how tall cylinder
is that's the height very good okay so
ready to play but what you have a look
at a sphere you have a look at the speed
up what measurement isn't that tells us
how wide it is it's the radius right but
then when you think about how to Talmud
it is awesome boy that's the same right
that's the whole idea of a speed no
matter which way you turn it it's gonna
be the same
so therefore around here let's draw a
circle I shall choose that goes around
like I guess the equator so what I've
got here is the largest circle that can
be made all the way around so it's kind
of like the equator this has a special
name by the way which we're going to
explore a little more next year it's
called a great circle I as opposed to a
small circle for example if this were
actually the globe right you've got up
the top here they are technically
Antarctic have you heard of the Arctic
Circle
do you learned that phrase before right
so the Arctic Circle is a circle up here
that when you're above there you're in
the Arctic right well that circle is a
lot smaller up here than the equator
does that make sense so this is the
biggest circle I admit now when you have
a look at this later
you might even label that for eight
seconds spent estimate the radius of the
Great Circle is the radius of the sphere
so actually once you know the radius of
the sphere the surface area is really
really simple the surface area is very
closely connected to the area of a
circle what's the area of a circle again
so surface area of a sphere with the
same radius is 4 PI R square that's it
now as I've said to you before when we
didn't mention it earlier and we have it
at the cylinder this way I think one of
my goals is for you not just to know
what is right but to feel that it's
right now I'm actually really crossed
because I made this early this week and
literally 10 minutes ago as I've worn
your food you tip I read it to me and
put a big dent in it or a few big dented
eventually but anyhow it wasn't that
good to start with as you can see it's a
good point so we'll just work with it so
here's my sweetheart okay now if you
look closely I mean this is the hardest
part when I was I was joining this
together for a bunch of sections and
then I glued all the insides together
and then when I get to the last one it
was hard so I taped it so to be funny
but I will show you when you take a 3d
shape and you look at the surface of it
and you unfold it until it's flat right
what do we call us that's an end it's
very good so I'm going to show you the
net for this change the net looks like
this so here is the net in fact if you
look closely you can still see you can
still see where those horizontal mines
are and how they correspond he there
nine of them it could have made more but
it would have been more taping okay so
this when you glue everything together
turns into this right now is that full
player square now it doesn't look very
obvious from here because plan spreads
out circles so I went one step better I
took the same net and then I cut it
apart okay now this is up this way this
is these nine pieces
and I've sliced them into lots and lots
of little sections and please don't ask
me how long this took because it took
far too long and this is the four PI R
squared that comes from B's once you cut
them apart so keep seeing can you see a
circle right great circle do you see it
right so this goes around the equator as
a word fact I put a flap okay but the
wonderful thing about it is you can view
it from any angle and it's the same
great circle okay so for plants where I
hope what you sort of go into the
formula sheet you think okay well this
is the thing I'm going for I hope this
is the image that comes into your mind
so that is let's take it up somewhere
just say it's a mental visual cue for
you is that make sense yeah one more
thing okay so is really simply this kind
of it so I want you know have a go at
using it just before you do do that I'm
not very closely related check nearly to
draw this with me closely related to a
sphere is half a sphere what do we call
Papa Jimmy's a hemisphere right so can
you draw one of those underneath this
yeah semi-sphere would be like well it's
a semicircle right so that seems like a
natural you can see here I sliced my
sphere in half it's a yes okay I'm going
to view this as a solid to the hollow
underneath so I've got the same radius
here now what might be the surface area
of this thing okay so just like with
this cylinder we've got a curvy part and
that's going to be what we slice it in
half so the surface area is going to
start with two PI R squared
that's the curvy part on the outside but
by slicing it across the middle you've
made a new area that's the splat pop
necklace but that's just PI R squared
do you agree
so therefore there's the flat part yeah
so you've got the curves bit when you
come a flat bit maybe you want to label
them like Sun so the surface area of
this if you include the plot that we've
cut off is going to be final squared do
you agree now all of these different
combinations of like slice it across
maybe you want to have like a a hollow
one if it were mob if this were actually
a bowl then you're gonna have the outer
curved part and then you've got the
either curved part do you agree they
shouldn't be the same if it's like you
know like my arm my sphere of paper so
it's like infinitely hints of the inside
and the outside of the same so if that
were the case if I slice slice it off
hollowed it out what would be the inside
and outside surface area I'm gonna get
this on the outside but then you're
going to get this again on the inside so
it's going to be 4 PI R squared right
the difference is that this is all on
the outside whereas if I cut it off
pulling it out there'd be inside and
outside that make sense so read the
question you can't reach that you can
see all right is this thing solid do
they want the flat bit do they just want
the COBE you should ha are they referred